This episode is sponsored by Motz
The term testis blue comes from long periods of sexual arousal
No stage ecstasy
But they are real, if they are
What actually happens
When you feel libido, it happens to your body many physiological changes
In men, arteries in the penis and testicles expand
Causing oxygen flow to these organs
At the same time, the veins constrict to prevent the return of blood
This causes high blood flow and pressure
Which causes erection, but does not know that
The testes extend to double their normal size
Yes that's right. Testicles grow larger
From the misinformation that the blood is irradiated, its color is blue
But in fact it is dark red, veins appear blueish green
Because of the skin above it
Because the red color has a longer wavelength than blue
This makes the red color absorption deeper into the skin
The blue light ends up reversing before it absorbs the veins
Making the roses appear in blue
As for the testes happen the same thing
Her veins appear blue, and if the period of lust extends
The non-oxidized blood accumulates in the testicles making it more blue
But this situation is not exclusive to men
Because blood goes to the vagina when women also
Blood flows to the female genitalia
Causes a medical condition known as the "blue vagina"
The good news is that the way of venting about this situation is very easy
The situation can be eliminated by getting orgasm
Or reduce sexual effects without any side effects or damage
Also the development was proposed
Ice bags may stop the pain
Sexually, the testicle blue and the blue vagina may occur for all
It's a real physiological condition because of
Because of the length of the period before intercourse or lust, but easy to stop
By moving away from sexual thinking
Or covert confidentiality
We would like to thank HMS for sponsoring this video
It is not surprising that problems arise for the penis
Or skin or hair loss, help prod
By communicating with real doctors
The tips are customized for you using medications
Or herbs to get you the best care
They also send other brands for the same expensive medicines
To make the price very small
Hair loss affects 66% of men under the age of 35
We'll be 30 this month and we're losing our hair
Motz provides a reliable place to get you a delightful and wonderful care
For these sensitive problems
Support our program by visiting the site
To get a visit to a doctor
This hair bag is only $ 5
Click on the "Sprecip" button and click "Next Week" with a new scientific video
Good-bye